best-selling author mark Stein has never
been in peach at this point it seems
frankly unlikely that he will be but he
joins us anyway tonight mark it's great
to see you hey good to see you too
Tucker
so all of a sudden Bill Clinton for many
years protected by the press is up for
grabs what is this well I think there's
a sense as you said that he is now
disposable but also at a son level I do
think there's a great shame and watch at
what the rationale for clintonism in the
90s loosed in in the following 20 years
the most interesting moment to me most
horrifying moment actually and the most
pathetic and self-serving moment in this
Today Show interview comes when he
pleads in mitigation and it's
interesting to look at his facial
expression as he says this that I had a
sexual harassment policy as governor in
the 1980s in other words that's the
that's the lesson the Democrats took
from this that as long as you struck the
right attitudes in public you could do
what you I mean try this in any other
aspect of your life Hey
hey bud you're you're double-parked oh
it's okay officer I voted for the
municipal parking lot expansion bill in
1973 that's basically that that's
basically the argument that Clinton is
making here because he passed the sexual
harassment bill in the 1980s because he
signed one as governor he's allowed to
actually assault women or enter into
degrading relationships could supposedly
consensual relationships that ruined in
the case of Monica Lewinsky a young
woman's life and and actually that's the
rationale that Harvey Weinstein and the
Schneiderman the New York Attorney
General and all these others and John
Conyers the big Democrat Big Shot who
was hosting trou sillas meetings in his
congressional office they were all
actually following that Clinton
rationale but because I have the right
attitudes in public I can do what I like
in
private Harvey Weinstein try to remember
his first defense was well I'm I love
abortion so back off leave me alone
right I wonder that well if so Clinton I
I confess I feel a little sorry for Bill
Clinton because I in my view this is
really about the Democratic Party
changing and rejecting its past but I
also wonder as long as we're gonna have
a reckoning with Clinton over his
behavior when do we get the reckoning
with all of his defenders in the media
the Washington Post reporter who said
that she would get on her knees for him
for keeping abortion legal the feminist
leaders who attacked Monica Lewinsky in
effect and dismissed the rape
allegations when do they get their time
under the spotlight for what they did
yeah and I think there's also other ones
too there were there were ones who
didn't attack Monica but I remember for
example being attacked in Canada by
femme a feminist columnist who said
you're wrong about Monica isn't a victim
here she's gonna make millions of
dollars she has had a miserable 20 years
nothing she said she was essentially
ruined and tossed aside by Bill Clinton
and as you as we saw in this interview
he thinks that he is the victim here and
he's out by the way he's on a book tour
peddling this novel he supposedly quotes
co-written unquote with James Patterson
and and is supposedly you know his most
ambitious work of fiction since his
deposition in the Paula Jones case this
this Clinton Clinton is getting a
bazillion dollars to put his name to
this ludicrous novel and Monica Lewinsky
is someone who has never had a fulfilled
career never had a fulfilled family life
and that doesn't matter because the
Clintons just discard people and move on
to the next bit of human debris yeah and
the media goes along with it of course
mark Stein thank you for that it was
great to see you thanks a lot Tucker